cleaner is an essential need for all not
just a luxury which is what my EU
policies have been put in place to help
cut air pollution across Europe
despite the improvement in Europe's air
quality pollution remains a serious
concern especially in and around cities
currently air quality standards are
exceeded in a hundred and thirty cities
across Europe burning coal and wood for
heating and cooking agriculture as well
as industry all play a role in causing
bad air quality the traffic is the
biggest contributor in urban areas
[Music]
various solutions exist and have already
been put in place
greening public transport building bike
lanes and new pedestrian areas and
setting up networks of charging stations
for electric vehicles many european
cities are busy setting up low emission
zones or introducing congestion charges
Berlin Milan London or Stockholm
this will further help reduce both
congestion and pollution
there are many more solutions possible
who knows what types of transport we
will use in 20 years but what we can do
right now is spend less time in our cars
and change how we move around to make
our cities cleaner and healthier
[Music]